hey everyone I have an update to you  from the Magnus trainer team we're  working on the tactics frenzied game and  with your help we've managed to improve  it the most requested feature was the  ability to play through the solution in  case you get a puzzle wrong so we have  fixed that let's make a wrong move you  can click at the bottom at the solution  and then you get the ability to play  through the right moves and figure out  what you should have done  we've also added hundreds of new puzzles  so that you don't have to play against  the same puzzle more than once but we're  still not done we're still making  improvements and in order to know what  to prioritize we need your feedback  leave suggestions in the comments and  next week I might be coming back with  something you suggested